hello everybody and welcome to my
introduction to sakuni so what is securi
and why do you care I plan to do
tutorials on BOSU Cooley and selenium as
they both provide a massive help in a
very similar situation so let's say you
know exactly what you want to do within
your Python program and you know how
you'd like to structure the logic of
that program but there's some more
in-depth things that you can't quite
figure out like let's say you don't know
how to log into a website or type things
onto a website interact with like maybe
some sort of JavaScript plug-in on a
website or possibly you want to interact
with programs on your own computer that
you're not quite sure how you can maybe
hit file and do this and whatnot within
that specific program so normally within
you know pure Python programming there's
a lot of coding that you would have to
do in order to do these things and so
what's the Coulee and selenium which
I'll be going into depth later on can do
for you is help you skip some of the
harder stuff and get straight to testing
your logic for the program so personally
I found that I just purely a lot of
times want to see what the end result is
gonna look like
like if I'm thinking about developing
some sort of program sometimes I don't
want to spend literally like probably
the hundreds of hours developing that
really in-depth back-end code and I just
want to test the logic and see if it's
worth putting in that time right and so
like the beginning of like my website
sent Dex
that was actually researched using both
selenium and Sakuni to decide if it was
really worth me putting in the time and
energy to code it purely within Python
because you really don't selenium is a
little better but sukui the downside to
Sakuni is it's very hard to scale Sakuni
because it's gonna it's going to take
control of your mouse basically so you
couldn't have
doing multi multiple tasks at the same
time I mean you could but it's still
it's still going to be using your mouse
and so the mouse can only be doing one
thing selenium is a little better and
it's gonna run within the browser and
you won't be sacrificing your mouse but
we'll get the selenium later so let's go
ahead and get started with sukui
the point of sukui is basically you know
you can read on their website it is to
automate anything you might see on your
computer and it's gonna be there there's
a specific IDE for it but it's going to
be using the same sort of logic that you
would use within Python so that kind of
same structure and syntax for a little
bit but you can see it's got like -
click the mouse it's literally a click
and to type its type and there's various
ways to do key presses like you can
control C control V that kind of stuff
so anyway we'll be getting into that
with a few sakuya tutorials here but to
start let's go ahead and download sukui
it's been a while since I've downloaded
a new version of sukui so I might be a
little unfamiliar with their newest but
this is all we want here let's download
this 1.00 see if we can find it I have
the windows and I think what we want is
right down here at the bottom the Sakuni
IDE let's open this up and see I believe
this is what we want so now what we want
to do is download that so it says we
should go here back to there download
page so we'll pop over there download
page here and I want I see there's an
API and an IDE for everything we want
the IDE I'm pretty sure the API I'm kind
of interested in I don't recall ever
using an AP I'll have to look into that
but maybe we can find a way did not
sacrifice our Mouse without it so anyway
let's take the IDE I'm got Windows 6
yeah windows 64-bit so I'm gonna
download this but they've got you know
for all the versions that you might have
but I happen to be windows 64-bit make
sure you download the IDE not the API
what we're looking for is this IDE so
I'm go ahead and click this and download
it
I'm gonna pause download while we're
waiting all right now that it's done
downloading I'm just gonna pull it over
to my desktop so we can work with it put
it down here so it's maybe a little
easier you see and we'll go ahead and
extract all and there we have it let me
close that drag it over here let's open
up see what we're dealing with here
looks like there we go okay so let's
download there open up the IDE here
alright this is definitely what we want
it looks very familiar so that's good
that's good make it into a window that
everybody can see now and this should be
what you're looking at if not then
something is wrong so up here is gonna
be where we're gonna script and then
these are some quick you know typically
used buttons within Sakuni and so this
is where you're gonna script out if you
had anything printing out this is like
your typical printout where it's gonna
pop this down a little bit and now what
we want to do so what I think would be
kind of cool is pretty much everybody
wants to or a lot of people want to use
sakuni to do stuff that they just don't
know how to do on their browser so why
not use the coulee - let's say we want
to use sakuni to login to a website for
example so this is actually a pretty
easy task for Saku Li and so let's go
through that